[Music]
okay all right so thank you everyone for
coming
what we want to do today is do an update
on where we add when it comes to working
with databases and our so last year we
introduced some concepts of how we see
the world when it comes to being able to
access remote data and be able to get
get results and analysis done in in the
best possible way for an R user to do
and the idea there is as I have here in
overview is to be able to send and push
all the computation back to to the
database and then just bring back the
results right if you think and if you
think in terms of what the Seco database
does is has the data and also has a
sequel engine and that sequel engine
does most of the stuff that we do in
local art today right so we group data
we filter data we select data and all
that stuff can be done in the database
so winter those just come to us of doing
that and we've been talking through -
through different conferences and even
to the class so what I wanted to do
today is kind of give an update or and
for do you know where more resources are
starting with this one
so Debbie daughter studio.com if you
work with databases in our that I would
absolutely suggest that you bookmark
this in your and your browser we've been
the one that we had last year had all
that the the basic stuff such as the
packages that we're gonna use as well as
the different backends that you can
connect to and how you can do that
through ODBC and the dbi package ever
since then we have added more best
practice articles and I think this is
one of the major things that you can
take from this the stock is like this
would be a good place to start if you
have questions about specific things of
how to do because what's going to happen
is that we're going
start where with simpler exercises and
then connect it more complex and there
may be some issues getting to that
through that complexity so it has that
site has a search bar that you can use
to be able to perform something like if
you're looking for schema information
out of work with schemas it's already
shows you all the results and you can
easily go to that article another thing
that we have here and as as far as as
you were reading through the
introduction for this talk about
techniques one of the things we've seen
that customers sometimes struggle with
is actually publishing the the content
right from a shiny after you have local
that you wanted to run now on something
like our studio konnekt for example or
shiny server pro or something like that
how do you transfer the credentials how
do you handle the security we have
actually three articles that handle
security and here so we would recommend
that if you are getting to that point
just like what Joe was talking about you
know as you go into production and try
to scale it up this is some this is
oftentimes comes becomes a challenge and
we have some resources here another
resources is the resource gives me as
their studio community there's a special
tag for databases so if you have
questions about how to do certain things
with databases and are you can post it
here also as you continue to learn and
get better at it you're more than
welcome to post answers because we
appreciate how the community comes
together and help help each other out
especially and especially as we learning
how well what things we can do better to
improve the these interfaces that we
have been working on so those are the
like two resources that the latest that
we have the other thing is I'm gonna
take a chance here and I want to
I'm gonna go real quick through okay so
the the script that Jonathan showed I
had a little demo for that but now after
seeing his super cool demo I'm very
self-conscious about it so you can see
it there and you just saw it earlier so
the next thing is also you connect and
sorry about the flickering but it I
don't have a way to show this in live
right now inner studio konnekt now
you're able to set environment variables
and those environment variables are
encrypted both in disk and also in the
memory so if you have a situation where
you need to have the credentials that
that shiny app is using in the published
version then you can leverage that and
connect so that's another new one that
we actually start the community a lot
based whenever there's certain
challenges to using something like a DSL
or or something like Kerberos for
example also we've seen as far as in in
a year's time how folks have that have
adopted using deep layer with databases
and let it do the translation for you
how it the start wrapping these more
complex stuff inside functions and they
start using things like things like per
for example and our Lang and so I'm very
excited about that because I was
expecting us to get to this point a
little bit longer time frame then then
then we are now so I think as you go and
and start practicing using connecting
with dbi and using odbc and using deep
layer that there's definitely techniques
that we're going to be expanding or the
articles in DB darcy um to cover this
kind of thing so once you start getting
and having those needs of doing
something like recursive sending
recursive sequel statements how we can
do that more economically against the
database another cool thing and I'm glad
this one's not flickering is that the
universe's X
I did a quick analysis of crime packages
as far as all the packages that depend
on D bi or DB plier and also that said
something about database or query inside
the title or description and ended up
finding sixty-one packages sixty-one
packages that essentially gives us more
functionality that the functionality I'm
talking about today
that adds two more things that we can do
with data bases so we have things here
like the connections that for example
there are Postgres we have DV parcel
here we have DVD player Tara data so we
have some vendor specific ones oh sorry
okay vendor specific ones as well as
here as well it wants that extend
functionality such as Teddy predict and
DB plot for example another thing I
wanted to show is that we have of those
61 packages posted here like when were
that last update done in cran and I was
surprised how basically at least more
than half been updated since last year
and next year 87% has been updated since
2017 I don't know if you have had the
same situation as I have that you go and
you find like a group of packages that
you really like or a package and you
found out the last time I was updated
was like 2001 so that I may not work out
for me
so this is some very excited about that
too so let's do a quick demo I want to
show some techniques for connecting
exploring visualizing data that we're
gonna have in a database we're going to
use several packages I have listed here
such as declare as we talked about we're
going to use leaflet and also a little
bit of per an hour line the data is I
figured that since we're in Austin and
we could use Austin open-data we're
going to do that so it's a data that's
available on bigquery that shows where
different 3-1-1 calls so you have made
9-1-1 calls that are for emergency
police three one one is like the
non-emergency police and we'll look at
this data here so let me switch over to
the demo
[Music]
I'm gonna do this here hopefully it's a
little bit more legible that way okay so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to connect to bigquery and I'm
excited about this one because it it's
data that's again it's public usually my
[Music]
thank you thank you usually data that I
demo is data that I have like in my
laptop on the sequel server or stuff
like that so this one is something that
once you have the code you can try it
out yourselves so we're going to do a
pointer to the 3-1-1 services and we're
going to use glimpse so this is deep
layer command that's running inside the
database and bring him back essentially
the same information that you would as
if as if it was local but it's obviously
not not in my laptop so I'm getting old
information here you can see we have the
complaint descriptions right we have
dead birds loose dogs animal service
stuff also when when it was open when it
was closed and most importantly because
it's gonna be what we're gonna do today
it's geo coded so we're going to look at
the longitude latitude of it to take a
look real quick see how big this data is
it's not huge right it's 640 thousand
records but again I don't have any of
that in my laptop everything's running
against the bigquery table here I want
to see that the top 10 most used
complaint description you'll notice that
it's running against bigquery and it's
telling me how many records is bringing
max is only bringing back ten records so
that's all that it went back and forth
the internet and me right now and I'm
realizing 600,000 records
live here right and it's immediately I
can see
the top 10 with no problems so that's
like the coolest thing ever right
because I'm using our mark down here to
publish all this information all this
analysis without having to preload all
this data I'm gonna do some data cleanup
real quick because some records were
improperly geo coded so doing that so
the first one is I'm going to do when
take just a loose dog complaints and see
where they are located right so I'm
gonna run this I'm going to use DB plot
so instead of doing a dot plot I'm gonna
do a raster plot I don't have to bring
back you know a very I think it's 41,000
records back to R and then have a bunch
of dots that are coming hard for me to
see where they are rather we can do a
raster so it's a lot less results but as
you can see here this doesn't say
anything right because we have no frame
of reference here where these dots are
located in real life so what we'll do is
we'll use a function called DB compute
raster the DB plot has and what that
does is it will run the same
calculations that we did for the raster
but instead of giving me a GG plot
object is giving me a data frame write a
table and what's cool is that again that
just every time I'm just calculating
against the the database and I'm only
bringing back 484 rows instead of the
$41,000
right so it's all the SP calculated I
want to since I'm gonna use leaflet I
want to draw the squares as you can see
here at Kandra of squares just with the
two points of reference here so I'm just
going to create a quick function as you
can see I'm using our length to do that
so you don't need to you know have to
create a huge package to start learning
tidy eval it's terrible so friend trust
me you were welcome to try it and you
start getting a lot of quick
functionality for yourself
I'm gonna run the locations against the
new function and something before I
forget about this function side what's
neat about it is that I can do locations
and then piped directly into mine a new
tidy eval function and say sighs and now
have my autocomplete function network so
I sent a start-up in lat
- and it works just like a if you were
creating your own tidy function so it
makes it was easily palpable for you so
that's one a big advantage that you gain
by using that so and then we're gonna
create our squares now you can see that
we have we went from just one for each
longitude latitude now we have the
squares themselves that I can draw next
I'm going to actually use leaflet to see
where they are so much easier you can
see it here but again now we know where
they are but we don't know what K
where's the concentration of loose dogs
calls all right so what we'll do is that
we're gonna the DB the DB top function
will return the number of records
concentrated in that and that square so
what we'll do is like we're gonna make
the the number the max number of course
the the more the redder of the of the
squares and the list number of course
the lighter red so it'll make it
visually easier to to see where the
calls are right so we're making it fancy
now and on top of that we also added
some pop up so I can click on and here
and see that there's 1200 calls in this
section of Austin 128 you see it's a lot
easier to to navigate so like this
section is so red I can even see what
area is in the map but very cool that
now I'm able to do this analysis again
against the database I don't have
brought anything so let's make it even
fancier and get add the dot where we are
right so this is where we are right now
hopefully Google Maps gave me the right
geolocation so if you're a local and I'm
not 100 incorrect based on blaming all
right so we see here we're where we are
and where the concentration is so we
feel safe now that we don't we're not
going to get to see too many loose dogs
apparently so that's coming worked out
great all right so good
okay got five minutes I'm gonna run
through this real quick with model DB
which is a new package that it's been
since 2018 you can actually run some
models inside the database one of them
is k-means so let me switch here what
it's doing right now it's taking all the
the longitude latitude and then it goes
three iteration and see if the the
average is less than the previous run so
basically what k-means done an hour but
it's doing that against the database
it's running sequel statements until it
finds one that's optimal to the
calculation so in this case it's going
to run a thing 17 cycles and then we'll
we'll be able to see it here
so it should be a last one so now I have
what it considers an optimal Center for
each of them and it keeps me three
centers is that's the default and as you
can see the the actual sequel statement
and you'll see that in the number C of
the calculations so let me run this
quickly now I can place the squares of
my three segments against against the
map and again I'm going back and forth
with the database
I am overlaying where my squares are and
then this last one hopefully have enough
time this is the one that takes a bit
longer because what I'm doing is I'm
using a per command to get good to do dB
to calculate the raster for each of the
center's give them a different color and
then you can see each color where the
each Center and where the calls are
right so everything I did I just did
against the database and I'm able to
have all my results and are and all the
computation and modeling and the rest of
that were done remotely so this is the
kind of thing that we want to continue
on building upon and obviously even
improve the concert relations we have
today so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]